don't you have a job interview on Monday
yeah I do
don't you to straighten your hair what
kind of job hey sorry I'm late my hair
was so nappy this morning hey Jody you
met Tracy yeah she's got the wild and
crazy hair something about I really
don't think they're gonna be hiring you
with your hair looking all wild like
that do you know who you look like
salon no I remember back in my day you
know you couldn't even walk in - oh my
god yeah I love this new like black
bohemian hipster thing you've been doing
with your afro no no no Macy Gray I know
you're into this natural movement and
you're all into this radical and
revolutionary stuff so tiny who do you
think you are Angela Davis oh no foxy
Cleopatra Shazam so if you ever
straighten your hair before do you wash
your hair I think it'd look really cute
on you gonna touch no your hair looks so
different every time they see you please
no please cut no you don't even get a
comb for this mom I don't even know if
it's you half the time you just you
don't look on my face with it see you
running your hands through it it's like
messin mudding you think I was running
my hands through this it's so crazy
every time what's it a pillow you even
walk through you're here skip nothing
I'm gonna sleep on up it's confusing for
me
oh don't understand when you stop
turning your hair looks so good with
your hair printer I've never really been
a Clementine guy before it's just so
unique and exotic
what I'm so voluminous you Richie yeah I
wouldn't Owens just lights down I would
just stop
Tracy your hair is so big and wild like
a lion you know when you burn and then
that's it
[Music]